après les organismes génétiquement
modifiée développée il ya 25 ans une
nouvelle révolution génétique se prépare
en agriculture un outil baptisé crise
peur permet de manipuler le génome des
plantes et des animaux comme jamais
auparavant
mais cette révolution s'annonce elle
aussi très controversé
faites la connaissance de la toute
nouvelle rouge de sicile cette tomate a
été créé au japon en 2021 à des temps
meilleurs a cette fois bien entendu
c'est le premier aliment issu de
l'émission génomique entrée au
supermarché
on a modifié six jeunes pour la rendre
plus nutritives cette prouesse est
l'oeuvre de la nouvelle vedette en
génétique le ciseaux moléculaires crise
peur
modifie le génome avec une facilité
déconcertante
après la médecine crise par révolutionne
l'agriculture
on a jusqu'ici indiqué le jeune homme de
plantes avec chris peur et des
chercheurs travaillent maintenant à
améliorer des animaux d'élevage
après les ogm crise par relance le débat
éthique de la manipulation du vivant
[Musique]
nous sommes sur la ferme expérimentale
de l'université de californie à davis
[Musique]
ce troupeau cachent des brebis rares des
brebis issus des coups de ciseaux de
crise peur
cette généticienne est fier de ses
rejetons
certaines de ces brebis affichent des
gains pas surprenant
[Musique]
la taille de cette brebis contraste avec
celle des autres elles ont pourtant tout
le même âge
[Musique]
on a des mâles et des femelles dont on à
inactiver le gène sox21 on s'attend à ce
qu'ils grossissent plus vite parce
qu'ils seront plus efficaces à
transformer leurs aliments c'est un peu
comme l'efficacité énergétique d'une
voiture il ressemble plus à une trieuse
carmin
[Musique]
pour parvenir à ce résultat la
chercheuse est intervenue dès les tous
premiers stades de la division
embryonnaires
grâce à kroos peur elle à inactiver un
gène clé qui régule la croissance
cellulaire des brebis la chercheuse a
par la suite introduit cet embryon
modifié dans une brebis porteuse
pour cent plus grosses
jusqu'ici les modifications génétiques
classique consistait à ajouter un gène
étrangers au génome d'une cellule pour
lui donner un nouveau caractère
c'est le cas par exemple du maïs
transgénique
le fameux maïs ogm de monsanto
mais chris peur modifie plutôt
l'alphabet des jeunes
le système cluster comprend un arn guide
est une protéine nommée casse 9 qui agit
comme un ciseau
la rn guide est une sorte de gps
il navigue sur les gènes et repère la
séquence a modifié
une fois en place la protéine casse neuf
couples brindas dna modifié
c'est au moment où la cellule tente de
se réparer que cru sport oriente sa
réécriture
crise peur peut ainsi modifier une
section d'un gène ou insérer une
nouvelle séquence d'adr
à terme que peut pourrait corriger des
mutations à l'origine de plusieurs
maladies en élevage le 6 on génétique
peut aussi produire des animaux sans
cornes pour éviter qu'il ne se blesse
à l'essonne vient justement de terminer
l'étude de ligne et deux vaches sans
cornes
ses vaches provenir de thon rouge dont
le génome avait été manipulé par
l'édition génomique
nous avons eu sa progéniture ici et on a
examiné la santé de ses vaches on a
regardé la composition du lait de la
viande mais rien n'avait changé ce sont
des vaches pour l'instant aucune vache
ni aucun mouton n'a encore gagné la
chaîne alimentaire d'autres études
seront nécessaires
mais déjà des universités et des
laboratoires travaillent à
l'amélioration des animaux d'élevage des
promesses sont immenses
[Musique]
sans surprise les premières applications
de crise peur a gagné les fermes
viendront des plantes
à l'université laval dominique michaud
voit passer une quinzaine d'articles
scientifiques par jour sur twitter un
nombre équivalent à ce qu'il voyait avec
les ogm il ya 25 ans
le potentiel de ça est très très élevé
parce que on est capable d'aller régler
des problèmes le ccrb de fait de faire
des gros changements dans jeune homme a
fait on fait des très peu de chances
donc vraiment de promesses le la
promesse aussi tient au fait que c'est
précis c'est rapide ça coûte pas cher un
peu partout les applications cru sport
foisonnent les chercheurs ont mis au
point des champignons et des pommes qui
ne brunissent plus des vignes qui
résiste à un champignon mortel de même
qu'une variété de riz hyper productive
pour dominique michaud ce n'est qu'une
question de temps avant que les plantes
manipulé par chris peur n'arrive
massivement au chant savoie d'avoir est
à mon avis en agronomie comme tel sur
les grandes cultures
développement
parce que c'est des plantes qui ont une
grosse valeur commerciale si les espoirs
sont grands les questions soulevées par
chris peu le sont tout autant
comment réglementer ces plantes sommes
nous face à de nouveaux ogm
la collection jeunesse non pas du tout
on ne le génome qui est déjà là par
exemple la tonhalle on va pas ajouté
rien on va aller faire six changements
puis on va ensuite régénérer la plante
avec son propre génome
mais tous ne sont pas de cet avis une
cour d'europe a rendu une première
décision en 2018 est statué que tout
produit provenant de l'édition génomique
correspond un ogm aux états unis c'est
tout le contraire
les autorités sanitaires ont conclu que
les plans manipuler avec chrysler ne
sont pas des ogm parce qu'elles ne
contiennent pas d'adr issu d'un autre
organisme
au canada le statut des produits de
l'édition génomique est sur le point de
changer jusqu'ici le concept d'aliments
nouveaux qui est au coeur de la
réglementation canadienne englobait à la
fois les ogm et les futurs produits
fabriqués par chris pr
or le fédéral veut maintenant les
exclure la raison les mutations causés
par crespo dans une plante serait
équivalente à celle obtenue par
l'amélioration conventionnels ainsi des
plantes et des semences crise peur
pourrait être mis en marche et sans
aucune évaluation de leur innocuité ni
de leur sécurité pour l'environnement
cette réforme ne fait pas l'unanimité
pour les groupes d'intérêt cette
révision du gouvernement fédéral ne sert
que l'industrie des semences ogm
elle augmentera les ogm au chant de même
que l'utilisation des pesticides qui les
accompagnent producteurs et
transformateurs de la filière biologique
sont également contre cette réforme les
nouvelles plan jasper risque de
contaminer leurs champs et de
compromettre leur marché ces acteurs
demandent maintenant au fédéral
d'obliger l'identification des saumons
strasbourg et d'assurer la traçabilité
de ces produits
mais il y a plus que les questions
réglementaires
crise peur soulève également son lot de
questions éthiques seo est la limite
jusqu'où on peut jusqu'où on doit aller
line létourneau est une spécialiste de
l'éthique animale elle a participé à la
rédaction de lignes directrices
européennes qui balisent la recherche en
édition génomique pour elle crut sport
bouscule notre rapport aux animaux
d'élevage ce sont des questions qui sont
très importantes puisqu'elles sont au
coeur de notre façon d'envisager de
venir de la production animale
la chercheuse attire l'attention sur le
recours accru aux peurs pour améliorer
le bien-être des animaux
si l'objectif est légitime il comporte
parfois des pièges ça nous empêche de
voir des problèmes fondamentaux de
conditions d'élevage
elle donne comme exemple les lignes et
de poulets sans plumes qui résiste mieux
à la chaleur ou même les poules est
aveugle mise au point à la fin des
années 90 cette expérience avait pour
but de réduire le stress des poulets
élevés en forte densité
ces poulets aveugle ou sans plumes ont
été obtenues par sélection
traditionnelle
mais chrysler permettrait aujourd'hui de
reproduire facilement ses lignes et
sur le plan exact ça vient montrer les
limites de focaliser ce la préoccupation
de bien être animal pour penser
l'acceptabilité de l'application des
techniques d'édition john holmes ou
d'autres techniques de modification de
l'adn
pour la chercheuse l'intégrité les
animaux d'élevage doit maintenant
d'idées la recherche en édition
génomique il ya quelque chose de
désespérant à penser que la situation
la moins pire ce qu'il ya de mieux à
faire pour des animaux dans des systèmes
d'élevage industriel qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est d'avoir des lignes qui serait
aveugle ou sans plumes ou d'élus et de
certains attributs parce que ça va
éliminer des problèmes de bien-être
enfin les initiés met en garde contre
les promesses parfois démesurée du génie
génétique
l'argument de la faim dans le monde par
exemple est souvent invoquée en
agriculture
encore une fois tant 10 h ils en on
adresse pas les causes de la faim dans
le monde on se sert de cet argument là
pour justifier d'aller de l'avant avec
des travaux comme ça parce qu'on est
emballé on est émerveillé par les
capacités de l'outil oui c'est un outil
qu'on peut utiliser dans certains
endroits pour où il ya des problèmes de
sécheresse et je ne rejette pas de
revers de la main l'utilisation de
l'outil je suis pas anti ogm je suis pas
anti édition génomique mais c'est un
outil
crise peut transformer à l'agriculture
de demain dans les champs comme dans les
élevages
mais pour qu'il y ait une acceptabilité
sociale de cette technologie il faudra
apprendre des erreurs commises avec les
ogm il y avait 25 ans un des
enseignements à retenir c'est de
développer des applications dont les
avantages ne seront pas uniquement pour
le bénéfice du producteur ou pour le
bénéfice du promoteur du développeur
mais d'avoir des applications qui ont
aussi un avantage pour l'animal pour le
consommateur ou pour la société dans son